صديقي القديم العزيز هكذا ينظر تشيلي بوتر
وعلى الاقل هذا ما سمعناه على هميشه قمه
منظمه شنغهاي للتعاون في سمرقند في
اوزباكستان فهل يظل بوتن وشجن اعز صديقين
الى الابد
اكد بوتن مرارا ان مستقبل روسيا في اسيا
الجغرافيا تفرض ذلك حكما فموسكو تجدوا
نفسها محاصره البلد الاكبر في العالم يمتد
على قارتين اوروبا واسيا فمن الغربي
والجنوب هناك حلف شمال الاطلسي الذي اخذ
يضم الاكثريه الساحقه من دول كانت تنتمي
سابقا الى حلف وارسو بينما تذهب فنلندا
والسويد للالتحاق بهذا النادي الذي يشكل
اكبر تحالفا عسكريا في التاريخ من الشرق
هناك الصين ثاني اكبر اقتصادا في العالم
تمتد الحدود الروسيه الصينيه على طول
اربعه الاف كيلو متر
76% من اراضي روسيا تقع في القاره
الاسيويه مقابله
24% فقط منها في اوروبا
غير ان العلاقات بين روسيا والصين تذهبوا
اكثر فاكثر باتجاه ان تتحول روسيا للشريك
الاصغر والمحور الجديد اي بعد الحرب
الاوكرانيه يبدو مختلى التوازن ولصالح
بكين بالطبع هنا الاقتصاد يحكم اصبحت
الصين في العام 2021 ثاني اغنى دوله في
العالم بعد الولايات المتحده بالطبع
نتيجهها المحلي 17 تريليونا و700 مليار
دولار فاين روسيا في الميزان في المرتبه
الحاديه عشره ترليون و700 مليار دولار
اكثر بقليل حجمه الاقتصاد الصيني يزيد 10
اضعاف عن الروسي وهذا قبل الحرب فانه
روسيا اليوم وان كبرت من العقوبات التي قد
تسحق طموح بوتا بالعوده الى واجهه المسرح
الدولي بامجاد الصوفيات وفرض روسيا كاندا
للولا متحده بينما ترى بكين في موسكو
شريكا من بين مجموعه شركاء ترتكز عليهم
حتى تتحول الى اكبر قوه عالميه بحلول عام
حقيقه الامر ان التحالف رغم اهميته لبكينا
وموسكو والاخيره بالدرجه الاولى
ليس بالنقاء الذي يحرصان على ابراسه وما
لا يقال في العلن التقطت مالامحه
الكاميرات ايضا
[موسيقى]
شو وينك
في المصافحه لا تلغي مرحله مفصليه في
علاقه العملاقين الشيوعيين اللتان وصل الى
حافه الحرب عام 1969 والخلافات لم تنتهي
الا في عام 19
مبادره الحزام والطريق واعاده رمزيات
الاعلام الجغرافيا تلعب لعبتها كازاخستان
ايضا ركيزه مهمه في المشروع الصيني بمرور
ثلث طرق الاستراتيجيه عبرهما الصين في
اسيا الصوفيه اذن اهميه حيويه لتنويع
مصادر الطاقه
ومن يخطط افضل من بكين كشفت علاقتها مع
استانا بهذا الاتجاه اعتبارا من عام 2019
ومن اسيا الوسطى الى اقصى الشرق الروسي من
بحيره بايكال في شرق سيبيريا الى المحيط
الهادئ كثيره هي منابع قلق موسكو هنا
والاختلال الديمغرافي الفاضح اولا اربعه
ملايين و300 الف روسيه يعيشون في المنطقه
التي تمثل ثلث مساحه بلادهم مقابل 109
ملايين صيني في الجانب الاخر في الصين
حضور الديموغرافيا كثيفه بنيه تحتيه حديثه
وعلى الجانب الروسي فقرا وانعدام للتنميه
وفراغ اخذت الجاليه الصينيه المتنميه
بملائه من ضمن رئيسيه روسيه مثل بلادي
بوست وخبرسك تحت تجتاحها الشركات الصينيه
لتغير البنياء الاقتصاديه للمنطقه ولماذا
ذلك الاجابات في الثروات التي يشكل خذ
الاحفوري كان نبطي والغاز مساحات شاسعه من
الغابات البكر نتحدث عن مخزون هائل من
المياه العذبه واهمها في بحيره بيكال التي
تشكل 20% من المياه السطحيه العذبه
الموجوده في العالم وطبعا هناك الثروه
السمكيه يجد الجار الصيني في هذه المنطقه
المحاذيه لحدوده مجال حيويا لدعم النمو
والطلب المتزايد على منتجات الزراعيه
يمكنها مستقبل ان تعويض تقلص الزراعه
لديها جراء التوسع العمراني وتسمم التربه
بفعل مخلفات الصناعه طموحات الصين مشروعه
هنا بموجب اتفاقيه الغاز بين البلدين
الموقعه في 2014 والتي احتوت على فقرات
مهمه تختص بتطوير البنيه التحتيه للشرق
الاقصى الروسيه